on ferme la porte pas de médiation t'as
pas besoin de médiation qu'on peut
parler
que si on en a pas besoin pourquoi on
s'est pas parlé depuis le 10 janvier
pourquoi la Terre syndicale n'a pas été
reçue lorsqu’elle a été honnêtement être
reçue par le Président de la République
c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui on est sur son
blocage donc bien sûr il y a des appels
téléphoniques des années 2000 qui peut
opérer dans la pas une seule discussion
sérieuses ça sera en train de se passer
dans le pays depuis le 10 janvier
19 janvier on est dans des mobilisations
qui sont exceptionnelles encore
aujourd'hui malgré la dernière qui était
il y a seulement quelques jours et on
nous dit mais non on n'a pas besoin de
ça de se parler on n'a pas besoin d'un
des médiation c'est une proposition qui
vient derrière syndicale elle est
formulée depuis à peine trois heures et
il y a déjà un refus donc c'est bien
qu'on a besoin de de se parler mais on
n'arrive pas à se parler la vérité bien
sûr on va même continuer à formuler
cette proposition par écrire avec la
personne syndicale d'ici la fin de la
semaine pour pour dire voilà il faut
mettre sur pause cette réforme des
retraites il faut la suspendre qu'on
appelle ça comme on veut c'est moi je
suis pas un pro de la rhétorique et on
se trouve on propose c'est selon la
proposition qui est la note aujourd'hui
de de demander à des médiateurs au
centre ou avoir de l'intermédiation on
appelle ça comme on veut pour que chacun
puisse faire état de ce qu'il propose
sur la question du travail et des
retraites et ensuite de se mettre autour
de la table dans un mois et demi deux
mois quand la poussière sera un peu
tombée je on a besoin et pour trouver
une espace un compromis possible et à
des cours de quoi on verra bien mais moi
je fais toujours je joue pas davantage à
l'intelligence collective à la
verticalité
financièrement ça va on verra le travail
il y a des
adhérents c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet pour nombre de de
manifestants
nous on a un système de de pour nous
adhérents de degré on a aussi des
caisses de grève professionnels dans
certains pays développent et on va le
voir bien la réalisation reste très
forte les salariés font des choix en
fonction de comme tel jour mais
on reviendra toute façon avec le nom de
la République a dit que le processus
démocratique c'était juste commencé le
Constitutionnel donc nous on passe à cet
exercice les démocratique dans le calme
dans la responsabilité puisque au moins
jusque là
non c'est pas bon pour la violence c'est
pas bon d'abord parce que la tarte au
carré aux personnes n'acceptable de
démocratie et la CGTP n'a aucune
ambiguïté sur le sujet on les progrès je
crois possibles ça provoque des fois des
réactions disproportionnées de
quelques-uns qu'on apolisent donc c'est
aussi avec un grand problème mais
c'est aussi la violence un problème
parce que on a un
masque de développement ça masque
l'immense majorités des citoyens des
travailleurs qui manifestent les villes
moyennes petites grandes mais où il y a
pas de violence mais dont on parle pas
allemand et donc voilà je on la redoute
la violence n'est jamais un bon une
bonne forme d'expression mais je vous
invite autant que possible évidemment le
panier ces oignons si elles existent ces
condames encore une fois mais à ne pas
masquer les mouvements social derrière
c'est c'est fait de violence aussi
regrettable et convenable
mais encore une fois et quand elle se
syndicaux donc on va dans le cortège ils
sont pacifiques et respectueux
les noms
[Musique]
il y a plein de gens qui connaissent
bien le sujet qui nous qui sont prêts
qui pourraient être prêt à rentrer dans
cette dans cette logique là je crois
qu'il faut faut vraiment regarder cette
mystérieusement donc allez on va mettre
la réaction de Monsieur bérand sur un
réaction sortie des conseils de
ministres peut-être que l'on peut
revenir à la raison et rentrer en fin
dans une vraie logique de discussion
nous l'aurons bien sûr vous dites c'est
et vous savez on connaît ça très bien
dans les entreprises quand il y a un
conflit social dans les grosses
professionnels quand on arrive plus à se
parler quand on a le dialogue un peu un
peu à l'arrêt et bien on fait en sorte
de d'avoir des gens qui sont dans une
chambre de neutralité pour pour voir
d'abord en comptant chacune des parking
pour voir un peu c'est quoi les points
des points de frictions des points de
proposition et de regarder ensuite
comment on organise ce dialogue pour les
semaines et les mois à venir pour
retrouver enfin un dialogue sur le
travail sur les retraites et une écoute
les cette médiation c'est aussi parce
que vous pensez que la décision de
conseil constitutionnel va arriver trop
tardivement par rapport à la situation
sociale
pour certains il faudra attendre le
Conseil constitutionnel c'est donc
potentiellement qu'un jour ou trois
semaines on va vivre avec cette course
là pendant 15 jours et trois semaines si
ça c'est pas de la part de
l'intersyndical arnaque de
responsabilité le problème de cette
médiation c'est quoi c'est un acte de
responsabilité dans un climat tendu donc
il faut le prendre comme tel
comme ça a été fait ce matin
[Musique]